why does if I need its own stealth jet
well there's been a proliferation of
stealth jets over the last decade Russia
flew its first one in 2010 China came
along and showed us its stealth jet in
2011 and they came up with even a second
one last year so Japan wants to get its
hand in the game and that's why it's
developing this new technology for its
own for a possible stealth fighter in
the future well it because that is
what's so special about stealth jets are
there's two key things about stealth
jets the whole point is to try and
reduce the radar signature there's two
ways they do one is to make the plane
very smooth have very few surfaces for
the radars to reflect off and one thing
they do they can do for that is to take
the missiles and put them inside the
plane so maybe your your vet regular
image of a fighter plane is seeing their
bombs on the wings not this one the
bombs are inside the missiles are held
inside the plane and another one is
having materials that help absorb radar
waves so for example on Japan's cockpit
on the hood it's got a very thick
plastic with the special coating to help
absorb those radar waves and that helps
reduce the signature so instead of
looking like a plane it looks more like
a small bird I mean some critics have
said well you can be a small bird but
not many small birds you don't see birds
flying at more than 700 miles an hour so
it's not invisible but it's harder to
spot well Chris Japan looking to replace
that f2 fighter jet that's that's been
around for ages and the hints that this
deltad model could become the basis for
that it's also got this huge degree of
nationalism and we had these comments
from an official of the Ministry of
Defence and all night if - replacing the
f2 with a Japanese made fighter jet
could be an option improved Japanese
aviation technology is key to the future
of Japan's defense stealth jets are
developed in Russia and China we must
come up with our own to compete against
them
so Chris which way is it going to go
here will Japan indeed go on to build
certified fighter jet well they've got
three choices they can use this
technology and develop it and then go on
to decide to build our own stealth jet
fighter jet or they can tie up with
someone like the US and build it
together or they can buy from outside
and it's worth pointing out that Japan
has already ordered f-35s which has
stealth fighter jets from the US it's
got more more than 40 of those on order
and they'll be starting to come out in
over the next few years the decision on
the replacement for these f2s will come
by the end of March 2019 so we've still
got a while to develop the technology
and see where that leads them